das liegt daran aber eben die ganze
wirtschaft ist im letzten die einzigen
die über die dörfer getingelt sind sich
vor jede feuerwehr gestellt haben und
gefragt haben wie geht es euch was soll
man denn machen war nur weil die afd es
kommt also bei den leuten dann anhört
wie können sich unter anderen sind wir
wurscht was ist los wenn sich ganze
landschaften politisch blau färben wir
fragen uns warum gerade in ländlichen
gebieten so viele afd wählen eine reise
über land durch wahlkreis 195 im
südosten von thüringen was wir jetzt
hier auf ersten blick sehe das große
graue ist unser nahwärmenetz dann leider
doch das ist meine alte wasserleitung
und hier vorne sieht man dann bei den
blauen rohr das hieraus theater schaut
dass darüber nicht anschluss das
glasfaser tino könig ist stolz auf diese
baustelle genau wie die anderen aus der
baugenossenschaft in remptendorf gahma
fernwärme abwasser und internet in einem
die bürger betreiben hier die
dorferneuerung in eigenregie inklusive
kläranlage
richtig funktioniert
darauf den auf dem zeug und das ist dann
zu einem biomasse
wurde
hilft dir selbst auf dem land ginge das
gar nicht anders sagen sie denn die
politik aber sie aus dem blick verloren
das war es in den ställen köpfen vorgeht
das können wir nicht nachvollziehen und
die politik auch die
landwirtschaftspolitik wird denn der
stadt gemacht wo viele eigentlich gar
nicht wissen was alles was bei uns
passiert
also ich habe keinen gesehen der
dorfmitte
wo ja die einzigen die über die dörfer
getingelt sind sich vor jede feuerwehr
gestellt haben und gefragt haben wie
geht es euch was soll man denn machen
war weil die alte es kommt also bei den
leuten dann anja die können sich und den
anderen sind mir wurscht
das ist also ich glaube dann darauf
meinen trend reihen der echt gefährlich
ist wenn wenn das so weitergeht
möglicher also mir persönlich macht das
ein bisschen angst ich möchte nicht dass
meine kinder
unter solchen herrscht quasi aufwachsen
müssen das ist einfach was
die haben einfach begriffen wie es
funktioniert wie mit mit angst und hexe
die leute vor sich hertreiben dass die
fdp bei der bundestagswahl hier stärkste
kraft geworden ist wundert sich nicht
über die jahre habe es eine entfremdung
gegeben zwischen der politik und den
bürgern von der abwasserentsorgung bis
zur borkenkäferplage habe man hier den
eindruck die politik würde an der
realität der landbevölkerung vorbei
agieren politik wird von oben nach unten
gemacht und eigentlich funktioniert
demokratie von unten nach oben wir
wählen ja die leute die für uns etwas
erreichen sollen und es kommt einem so
vor als wenn oben diktiert wird was
unten umgesetzt werden muss und auch
nicht an jeder stelle umgesetzt werden
kann aber das ist scheinbar da oben egal
zu sein dementsprechend gaben die
denkzettel verteilt
fast überall in der region ist die
politische karte blau auch im
benachbarten ziegenrück letzte fotos
hier bürgermeister horst matzke will
diese straße sanieren lassen endlich
denn sie warten schon lange darauf seit
meiner amtszeit
2010 wir waren damals im bereich chancen
haben uns dann raus gewirtschaftet und
jetzt die letzten zwei jahre kommen
sagen okay jetzt können wir es angehen
jetzt haben wir das geld da es wird
damit beginnen können es reicht immer
nur stückchenweise das meiste geld geht
für pflichtaufgaben und umlagen drauf
aber immerhin die promenade im kurort
verlängert beleuchtung erneuert
ziegenrück hat zuzug und das
vereinsleben läuft gut und doch
48,1 prozent für die fdp bei der
bundestagswahl im rathaus sind sie
ratlos
es ärgert mich sie haben sich sagen weil
das einfach kontraproduktiv ist aber
warum das so ist kann ich nicht sagen
ich denke mal die läden abgestumpft euch
durch die ganze entwicklung durch die
geld durch die auch die wahlergebnisse
durch durch alles weshalb jetzt im land
passiert eigentlich die unsicherheit
irgendwo dann kam noch dazu das ist ja
auch wieder das was man überall hörte
medien und auch selber feststellt dass
halt die rede da richtig abgestimmt sind
und sich dann auch ein egel manchmal
irgendwo sind dass bürger die ihre
meinung äußern wollen die die
möglichkeit haben das dort frei zu
äußern wir hatten viele jahre am ende
das andere system
und jetzt ist die möglichkeit gegeben
was ihn ärgert dass der protest immer
erst an der wahlurne ausgedrückt wird
dabei gäbe es genug möglichkeiten sich
auch vorher einzubringen
sicherlich den einen oder anderen bürger
geben da mit gewissen frust hat
vielleicht auch mal und öfter statt paar
monate ist möglichkeiten donnerstags
habe ich einen sprechtag hierherzukommen
sich zur äußerung bei nicht grüner
gesagt die einwohnerversammlung ja immer
hier habe ich mir am öffentlichen
stadtratssitzung mitunter würde ich mir
wünschen dass es mehr genutzt wird
desinteresse oder misstrauen die
parteien bindung ist im osten geringer
das lässt sich seit jahren beobachten
und auch im kleinen sucht manch einer
kaum kontakt zu den entscheidungsträgern
ja so ein paar projekte kommen jetzt
schon ein
beispiel
warum
kleine fortschritte hier im ort würden
die großen probleme der region nicht
aufwiegen sagen andere einwohner die
wahlen für sie das ventil das kreuz bei
der afg sei kein bekenntnis für rechts
sondern ein signal an die anderen
die ganze wirtschaft kaputt kommunisten
letzten preis schon
das spiel
irgendwie
die unzufriedenheit
von ziegenrück bis zur stadt bad
lobenstein dauert es mit dem bus rund 40
minuten
wer hier mit pferd hat entweder kein
auto keinen führerschein oder viel zeit
zum warten als auf dem land ohne auto
wird sehr schlecht also man braucht
zusätzlich noch ein auto wenn man kann
aber wie gesagt die leute die älteren
leute die mit im bus mitfahren die
können ja kein auto fahren und dürfen
nicht mehr auto fahren und die nutzen
dann schon den bus dann sind wir auch
froh dass auch wert auf themen wie
klimawandel oder verkehrswende schauen
sie hier auf dem land mit einem anderen
blick die afg greift das auf genau
richtig sagen die einen übertrieben die
andere
meiner ansicht nach teilweise von aids
kampagne oder sowas also er hat manche
sind halt mich mit nichts zufrieden und
ich denke mal wegen sie war sehr viel
durch kroner zeiten die waren ja also
ich muss sagen wirklich haben da
geteilte meinung gehabt
fünf leute im bus typisch weil er selten
fährt wird er wenig genutzt weil er
wenig genutzt wird fahren weniger busse
ein teufelskreis und für valeria käfer
ein problem sie ist altenpflegerin ihr
spätdienst beginnt halb zehn uhr abends
der letzte bus fährt aber schon um halb
fünf und sie muss stunden überbrücken da
habe ich ja mindestens drei stunden dass
ich irgendwo hinkommen muss weil ich
mich auf arbeit kann und das ist halt
das was einem ärgert dass da abends
später kein bus werden der ländliche
raum müsste stärker finanziell gefördert
werden um solche nachteile auszugleichen
sagt auch der geschäftsführer des
kommunalen busunternehmen
sie haben hier genauso viele einwohner
wie in der landeshauptstadt aber eben
vier weitere wege
daseinsvorsorge ist bestimmt immer
demokratie bilden egal ob das öpnv also
dass und wasserversorgung ist
elektrizität es ist eine daseinsvorsorge
und wenn die nicht vorhanden ist wird
das sicherlich fonds davon bin ich
überzeugt auch für ihn ist das
wahlergebnis nicht in erster linie
zustimmung zu den inhalten der afg
sondern protestwahl ich sagen wenn ich
das wahlergebnis interpretieren sollte
wir hatten vor afd wurde halt in
thüringen oder in den neuen
bundesländern vorwiegend links gewählt
wir sehen dass links das dieses jahr
nicht erreicht hat unserer
ministerpräsident spricht derselbe
erfolgt dass seine partei in einer
ausrichtung benötigt ich glaube man hat
die afg aus protest ausgewählt um
sicherlich auch was zu verändern auch
unter umständen über info die afg spiele
den frust aus ergebnis in thüringen
knapp 25 prozent in remptendorf gemacht
dass vielen sorgen auch welchen einfluss
die afg erfolge auf das image der region
haben also 40 prozent der menschen in
thüringen haben eben nicht diese braune
soße gewählt das darf man halt auch
nicht vergessen ich finde das wird im
moment gerade wirklich extrem breit
getreten wir sind ja alle so brauchen
und wir haben alle
75 prozent der menschen haben die nicht
gewählt und ich glaube auch dass wenn
das weiter in die richtung gehen dass
wir alle in diese ecke gestoppt werden
weil man so man kommentare liches wir
bauen in sound room und so fühle ich
mich auch angepisst ganz persönlich das
ärgert mich durch ihr projekt sagen sie
hätten viele im ort besser verstanden
wie entscheidungsprozesse funktionieren
politik und bürger müssten da
gegenseitig aufeinander zugehen sie
hoffen dass diese wahl zu einem
stärkeren blick zu ihnen den menschen im
ländlichen raum führt